welcome back to new rockstars this is
big question the show that gives you too
much information about how the entire
fabric of reality can be messed up
by one person having a temper tantrum
[Music]
i'm empty and i am here today with the
one and the only
eric voss how you doing eric i'm doing
good mt hey if that one person throwing
the temper tantrum is loki laffy son
odinson i'd happily live in that world
same here i mean loki's got a totally
fine mind that'll be totally fine
a perfect universe
yeah let's just give him a chance give
him a chance to burn everything down and
just see what he does
right you know i would see his glorious
purpose manifest i would love a universe
where everyone was just wearing those
gigantic horns
just everyone yeah mandatory let's
normalize that let's normalize uh
horn crowns as we slowly creep into the
next phase of the mcu
we keep seeing and hearing the word
nexus pop up all over the place i mean
in one division episode seven
the in-universe commercial defined wada
as a nexus being which was later
revealed to be an intended message from
one
dr steven strange which i i wish we saw
but that's okay
and now in the first episode of loki we
are showing that there's this whole big
bad bureaucratic task force
working around the clock to keep nexus
events from ruining the sacred timeline
we know that there's a lot of nexus
history in the marvel comics so that got
us thinking about this week's big
question
which is which characters in the mcu
might be nexus beings
yeah that's a great question empty what
does the word nexus mean to the msu
and let's look at all the different
definitions and what we know from the
comics and see if we can figure out what
loki's next move is going to be with
this
as we look ahead to titles like doctor
strange and multiverse madness
let's do it so in the marvel comics
nexus being sometimes referred to as
nexi are extremely rare and powerful
entities
that have the ability to upset the
future by affecting probability
as well as the just whole flow of the
universal time stream
and they're really detached from any one
reality
rather than them existing in a reality
the reality kind of exists in
them right i guess you could kind of say
uh
they transcend the reality i think is
the best way to talk about it okay okay
yeah because they are so powerful they
really need to be kept a close eye on by
groups like the tva and the time keepers
really we were first introduced to this
concept of nexus beans in 1990
in avengers west coast volume 2 number
61 in this comic
immortus aka kang the conqueror uh he
was a keg the cocker yet which is known
as mortis it brings
a bunch of villains from the future to
the present and it's in this issue that
wanda maximoff is revealed to be a nexus
being nexus b
well which was really just like uh late
80s early 90s like let's just come up
with new weird words with the letter x
in it that we can
it just makes um sound like the word
nexus is actually the primo word
to make something sound cooler it's like
oh my god it's my it's my nexus toaster
it just toasts bread in a nexus way
totally nexus dude
it was before quantum in the mcu now put
quantum in front of everything just put
nexus in front of everything
wow yeah that's what we do here oh you
see my my nexus staff oh that's a nexus
store don't go through that one
oh yeah you're next owen wilson is on
point bro it is
on point it's so good i do my best yeah
no kidding
so back to the comics later in scarlet
witch volume one number four that was in
1994 it is established here that only
one nexus being exists on each of the
parallel worlds of the multiverse
so earth 616 the main marvel comics
timeline
that nexus being is the scarlet witch in
this comic she's visited by
lore and next site from another
dimension that has the power of
necromancy so she's consumed by her own
world and since then
has ventured into other realities to
consume their dimensions
and empty i know you're a fan of uh the
i'm a big fan of laura in the comics
because
i um i actually have i think our one of
these are first appearances
uh i forget which one like these are
back
and uh at one point during one division
i seriously thought that agatha harkness
was
lore or a combination between agatha
harkness in the comics
and lore because uh lorp is a
necromancer and agatha harkness was
doing some
necromancy i i assumed that she was
doing some necromancy type stuff with
with piano we had a lot of assumptions
about
what agatha harkness was doing she might
still have some necromancy going on we
know she killed the dog
um but resurrect it i hope so
there's still time there's still time
mcu character to come back it's sparky
so next i each have unique powers and in
the scarlet witch's case it's hex power
hex magic
but uh no matter what individual powers
they may have each nexus being
has the ability to alter reality to
change the fabric
of the world around them right so while
nexus beings can affect the flow of time
and therefore
are potentially super dangerous to their
reality they are also considered a
keystone of the multiverse
so without nexus beings anchoring each
universe there wouldn't be the stability
to maintain the multiverse
and it plays into the importance of the
organization like the tva to watch over
all these nexus beings like you need a
nexus being to exist in order to
maintain the fabric of that reality
but yet that same nexus being has the
ability to tear
down that reality so it's really they're
they're all very unstable themselves but
that
instability is crucial in a way yeah
like it's like it's like they're
they're keeping everything together but
like they could be unstable so like you
need an organization like the tva just
or you know your doctor strangers to
just keep an eye on
the scarlet witch which is why agatha
harkness was freaking out when she
realized who rwanda was and her foot
when she realized her full potential
and she's like oh my god like what are
you like you are the scarlet witch and
you're crazy
so the founder of reality is going to
die
you can fix anything mom fix it dead
right now i'm freaking out yeah you're
too powerful you're god level power
right so uh just to run down some uh
quick list of the
known uh next speeds in the comics of
course scarlet witch that's
earth 616. and uh we see that really
play out in the house of m comics right
that we hoped would come about in one
division but it seems like they might be
going that direction and doctor strange
multiverse madness
where um juana maximoff just basically
resets
reality chaotically over and over and
over again uh until
creating this house of m reality where
mutants are uh running society
uh and that leads to a whole battle that
has her say no more mutants
and then a lot of mutants just poof uh
erased from existence
there's another nexus being is uh elian
ellen
helen degeneres uh she was a witch queen
that was also a nexus bean
laura absorbed her powers and possessed
her physical form
uh there's a character leonard tippett
uh who didn't know he was the nexus
being
almost got a nuclear holocaust on earth
by affecting probability the watcher saw
what was going on
and then kind of manipulated the
avengers into stopping so you're telling
me that there's a nexus being named
leonard tibbetts and he's like one of
the most scariest beings
oh better watch out for leonard tibbett
the nexus being
i'd be afraid of leonard tippett even
before now he needs a nexus b
keep an eye on that one anyone named
leonard tibbett capable of anything make
sure you're really nice to leonard
typically
yeah he's he's the one who will snap
first yeah he's got he's got lists
i really hope we don't have a leonard
tibbett watching another
nexus being that pops up is uh one named
seismic
uh it's a magic wielding being that
doctor strange and mordo had to deal
with it's time traveler from the 31st
century that absorbed all the magical
energy in the mad
in the marvel universe in order to
recreate the big bang so life could
start over
a lot of these nexus beings just kind of
show up in one-off comics
and they just needed to heighten to like
some kind of god level uh reality
rewriting being
that's an example here and fun fact
seismic name backwards
genesis
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now uh merlin actually yes our friend
from the
camelot era uh does reside in a pocket
dimension near
earth called otherworld uh was even the
sorcerer's supreme at one point
technically as immense magical powers
now of course we've skipped over the one
who we know for sure is coming in the
mcu hang the conqueror yeah
yeah he is uh the one of the greatest
time traveling villains of marvel lore
uh and we'll show up in ant-man the
guacamania hopefully and loki that'd be
cool to see him
establish there just makes a lot of
sense to see him now franklin richards
in uh some of the what-if comics uh
becomes like a nexus being
and then vision from earth90110 um
that was uh my favorite teen soap opera
version of vision uh
there is a nexus being version of vision
named ultravision
uh same powers as earth 616 vision but
uh in his reality he's kind of the
leading guide to the world as well as
the head of the avengers in that reality
gene gray from earth 9250 and of course
gene great the mutant
incredible psychic powers access to the
phoenix force right it's considered uh
next being there
and then uh odin borsen from earth 9260
similar
to uh that of odin boston from earth
6166 this version is the true nexus
being now the term nexus
comes up in other places like in marvel
comics there's what's called the nexus
of all realities
right and this is a physical space that
forms the cross-dimensional gateway
between the multiverses
uh and it first appeared in marvel's
fear number 11
1972 that's the man thing comics
so basically a couple kids are goofing
around and one of grandpa's occult
textbooks
uh and then they open up the nexus
before getting bored they head off to
the movies and left a man thing to deal
with it but
um it just kind of leaves it there so
there's that but then there's also
another
version of nexus in the mcu
that should have been age of ultron when
tony stark visited what was called the
nexus uh
trying to track down it's the internet
what is it
this gen it's the internet they called
it nexus it might have just been a
simple term for it because the nexus
just means like a gateway across things
that should be separate
right so i think that's why it was
called that but who knows maybe that
could be
uh revisited as like something that
allowed for gateways between dimensions
to be open
because it just uh is accessing
information networks
behind the barriers of time and space
check this out
take a look at this jesus christ it's
also interesting that you have a
character like
a vision and white vision that have uh
had this connection with
wanda's hex reality if they're
irradiated by her cmbr
and if they have the kind of information
access that
ultron had uh could that lead to some
kind of nexus opening up through that
character
oh yeah like that that'd be a really
really great opportunity to do that
because they are
irradiated by this this chaos magic now
especially white vision
like because because white vision or
vision i guess used to be powered by
mind stone energy and now white vision
is now powered by
chaos magic so in uh speaking of wanda
vision that's where
nexus has come back and is presented a
way that seems like
this is where the mcu is headed starting
with uh this commercial for nexus
antidepressants
and the way it was described by the
voiceover is interesting they say
this nexus drug can quote anchor you
back to reality or
the reality of your choice and this ad
was made for
wanda or at least uh you know the
reality warping powers that wanda admits
i just think it's a manifestation of her
nexus powers
and i think the fact that in earlier
drafts of one of vision the commercials
were definitely gonna be coming from dr
strange reaching out to her
uh tells us that it's it's coming from a
place of authority it's not just there
by accident that there was an intention
by calling this nexus i wonder if like
wanda is one of the few people that it
from her native universe that can
actually
go to a different universe without you
know breaking down or being like
rejected because they're not native of
that universe right so
um i mean obviously we're going to do
some universe hopping and doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness
via miss america most likely but you
know just i just want to see like
how that nexus moniker or title um plays
out i love this line the commercial it
says
because the world doesn't revolve around
you
or does it like it's it's starting to
give us
like the the meaning to characters who
are nexus beings
this is how it's going to feel like i
think one division was just like a
sample
of what will be on a macro scale in
multiverse of madness
wanna just created a pocket dimension
that spanned the limits of a town
but what happens when that pocket
dimension spans
an entire planet uh a galaxy you know
uh an entire universe uh gets worked
around
this one individual person and from her
point of view this is normalized it's
what it's always been
it does you don't remember what came
before it's actually similar to what
thanos was going to do when in game
right
he was going to use the stones that they
had collected for him to
tear the universe apart and start over
and that the
people who populated that new universe
would have no idea what came before
right that's essentially what wanda's
doing now they'll be nuts absolutely not
now what's interesting
is that loki is giving us a more
specific and technical
uh understanding of how nexus events
occur on a very very small scale
um and i don't think it suggests that
every person every variant
who creates a nexus event is a nexus
being
um because it's kind of suggested that
anybody from loki
to josh fadom's character to that one
scroll to any of the detainees
to mr um uh rocky bullwinkle character
the yellow dude can become a nexus being
i think it happens
all the time and i think it's suggesting
that if these characters become
masters of it then they evolved
so the idea is they show these nexus
events occurring right you see it in
miss minutes cartoon segment where you
see this guy
uh he uh jumps onto a new
branch in time to go off of where he was
supposed to go from the destin
sacred timeline now in this cartoon they
don't specify
what enables this in avengers in game
the ancient one said that the removal of
an infinity stone was kind of the key
that created this branch reality but uh
they don't show
any of these other detainees other than
loki having any particular infinity
stone on them
i don't know how josh fadom's character
whose dad worked for goldman sachs that
sounded like would be able to possess
any of these infinity stones i was just
like how did you get into trouble my
dude with the tva what did you do
but maybe that is true maybe each of
these people like they
accidentally got their hands on the eye
of agamotto
uh or they accidentally held uh the
suitcase containing loki's scepter not
realizing what was inside
uh or the orb that contained the power
stone rolled over to them
uh from when like star-lord and rocket
and gamora were tussling over it and
they just picked it up they're like
some scroll on zandar was like i guess
this is mine now
and walks off with it and creates a new
branch timeline not realizing he's a
variant the way loki didn't realize he
was a variant when he took the tesseract
yeah like that's what i love about this
show cause like there's heavy
like the rick and morty is very strong
in this show like the vibes
and like the oh my god like that dude
could have been from anywhere in the
timeline he could have been in the
distant future
like we don't know who this mysterious
golden goldman sachs
son of the goldman is or was now that
he's dead or dead or do you think he was
killed there or just like
reset back to where he was supposed to
be because i think killing him would
disrupt the timeline that he was taken
from would it not
yeah i think you're right because then
maybe it does more of like a reset type
thing because in the in the comics the
red canon
was said to rewind you in the timeline
so like if i'm not mistaken so like it
would make sense if his
molecular structure or whatever was just
like all right you're going
like back to like to the moment where
you branched off and like everything's
either way i hope it was really painful
like i hope being rick cannon on the fly
like that is just like
i feel my cells and my molecules moving
backwards and it hurts
that's what i wanted tenet to be i
wanted it to be
not just a simple predestinate time
travel story i wanted it to be like
it required an immense amount of energy
expense by people who would move
backwards through time
that would do irreparable damage to
their bodies as they move backward in
time and that's why i thought like
oh that's why they have to wear oxygen
masks that's why you see people in
hazmat suits
like i thought like people who move in
reverse entropy are like a weird kind of
radiation that um
causes their cells and molecules dope
but no
nope it wasn't that imagine if they like
like de-aged the more that they use
their power which is like i'm using
chrono energy so now i'm getting younger
yeah i'm sort of like monster girl from
uh invincible yeah no oh that'd be great
or like in
that movie looper how you saw paul
dano's characters like his
uh like his limbs were falling apart his
fingers were getting erased and it
seemed to hurt like
staggering around i always think of pain
loki give me some pain
[Applause]
but i think the idea is that loki is
basically suggesting these nexus events
are small little isolated events that
happen by accident
but but but if uh some character gets
a good handle on this if anybody starts
to realize
the power that comes with that and then
intentionally creates nexus events
that makes them uh on par potentially
with nexus beans because at that point
they might not even remember what their
home timeline was
they're just jumping from branch to
branch to branch to branch
until it becomes a giant mess and at
that point what's the difference between
yourself and a god
[Music]
it's still true i really that's a really
good point that's a fantastic point just
like you are destroying
the fabric of reality on multiple levels
that could be how we got kang
you know like that could be how kang
started is it may have started as an
accident and then he's like oh i got
away with something
and it's like screw this infinity stone
i figured out how he can do even crazier
[ __ ] than that
right uh because we saw the tva is more
powerful than infinity stones
infinity stones are paperweights to them
oh my god that was such a good image it
was so
powerful and striking i was like oh my
god there's so many
so looking ahead and nexus beans are
going to start being the thing in the
mcu
which characters in the mcu will be next
to speeds well
scarlet witch obviously right i think
yeah she's got to be the nexus being for
our dimension of the mcu which is
technically
earth nine nine nine nine nine five
nines five nines
um but now um we may see reality where
loki could evolve
into a nexus being the god of mischief
like he's already one step
on that path by uh moving out of his
home timeline
into the tva and if he gains the tva's
trust
and works with them he may gain enough
power
uh to affect all of reality and the
future of the marvel universe
oh my god like you know that this man is
making a play
to do just that like he's trying to i
i'm just so nervous about what loki's
gonna do by the end of the series like
oh my god but yes yeah loki
is definitely a contestant and i think
another contender hopefully loki will
introduce us to is kang the conqueror i
think
uh if you bring in kang the conqueror to
the mcu and ant-man the was quantomania
and don't make him nexus level powerful
i think it does a disservice to the
character
i think kang is such a complex weirdo
and we need to see him detach from his
uh
whatever timeline he came from he's a
guy who looks at timelines like uh
as what outfit of clothes he wants to
wear that particular day so yeah
definitely kang is the nexus being but
do you think vision white vision uh
or some other form of vision could be
revealed as a nexus being if they want
to bring
if they want to restore white vision as
the red vision form like they did in the
comics they brought it from another
reality
merged him with white vision's body and
we got vision back do you see that
happening in the future empty
i i mean it's possible but i think that
if any sort of nexus type deal was going
to happen
it would probably tie into what we were
talking about earlier with the fact that
you know white vision now runs on chaos
energy
and you know if we're going to be
running into potentially this hasn't
been confirmed yet but like if
schumacherath or some other multiversal
threat yeah
is going to be um on the horizon he
could use
uh white vision as an avatar sort of
because
he does have this chaos energy so any
chaos entity out there in the multiverse
could potentially make that white vision
into um
uh uh nexus being maybe who knows yeah
but
i could see that yeah um now i
have to ask about doctor strange because
he's someone who seems like
as a master who knows how to navigate
the the multiverse
um he could rise to that occasion
however
he specifically told tony stark that my
goal is to protect
your reality douchebag which makes me
feel like he's contained within
a reality as opposed to one who's just
kind of ambivalently detached from any
one particular one so
i don't know maybe a multiverse of
madness will be a battle between doctor
strange and wanda over
who gets to be this universe's nexus
champion that would be so that'd be
crazy now
uh looking ahead beyond these titles in
the mcu
uh there are characters like jean grey
you know phoenix like
she hopefully if they do something where
the x-men are in a different reality and
multiverse of madness just
merges those realities i think jean grey
would have been the nexus being of that
reality i think that'd be really cool to
see
that'd be super dope you know you know
how uh x-men days of future past ended
with uh
logan and talking to patrick stewart uh
why am i blanking professor x
he's talking about professional accent
the game's like we gotta fill you in on
some stuff
what if they were what if like the mcu
like retcons that'd be like yeah they
were talking about
you know some what's some stuff
happening in doctor street's the
multiverse of madness and like
how jean grey has to fight wando or some
stuff and in a nexus battle or whatever
um so it'd be it'd be interesting and
that'd be fun yeah i mean
another reality that could get merged
here would be you know
something from the supernatural realm
like hell like uh
methisto could totally be 100
mepisto could basically be anything he's
a pandora's box you know however you
want to use them you could you could
figure it out it's true but i also think
uh if they ever wanted to bring back
thanos uh the fact that thanos uh
vanished from his 2014 timeline
i could see him being someone who
transcends uh realities
but how about this do we think uwatu the
watcher would be considered
a nexus being i don't think so i think
he's just more
like a uh you know just a observer i
don't think he has that
much power because like there's been a
lot of times where he
like a lot of the times in the comics
he's just been like hey guys i've been
watching some stuff and you guys need to
interfere because i
i can't and like i don't have that yeah
the power to do anything yeah i think
watchers are a special category right
where they are um
they are outside of realities but they
don't have to be a true nexus being you
have to have the ability to rewrite it
right
to your own um you know preference and i
don't think
uwatsu does that but like like we
mentioned earlier a huge contender
is uh franklin richards because we're
getting the fantastic team very soon
and i think it would be very wise if
kevin feige introduced the fantastic
four with the kids already born
so like franklin richard is he's diesel
he is a very
huge force in the marvel universe so
like if anyone's has the potential to be
another nexus being it's franklin
richards i think there's a lot of
potential there i think that'd be
awesome to see well that kind of covers
i think everything we know so far about
how the mcu is approaching this whole
concept of what a nexus being
is so hopefully that gave you some
clarity as we head into episode two
three four five and six of loki
well great job eric i like that
explanation but before we dive into our
bite size questions we gotta give you a
word
from all the lovely people about your
big question first we want to thank our
friends at mint mobile for sponsoring
this episode with big wireless providers
there's always a catch right that's
what's cool about mint mobile and their
premium wireless service starting at
just
15 bucks a month there's no catch mint
mobile secret sauce is that they are the
first company to sell wireless service
online only so by cutting out retail
stores
there's no crazy overhead costs that get
passed down to you in the form of
mystery fees
instead mint just passes on sweet
savings directly to you
here at new rockstars philips switched
to mint mobile and he really likes it
it's the same quality services old plan
but at a fraction of the cost
and he got to keep his phone and his
phone number for people looking for
extra savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just
15 bucks a month all plants come with
unlimited talk text and high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network
and if you're not 100 satisfied met
mobile has you covered with their 7-day
money-back guarantee
so switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and to get the plan
shipped directly to your door for free
go to mittmobile.com
big q that's mintmobile.com bigq cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at midmobile.com bigqueue we also want
to thank honey for sponsoring this
episode we've all had the experience of
shopping online
being ready to check out and then
there's that blank box next to the
coupon code just taunting and mocking
you for not being savvy enough to be
saving money on that pair of shorts
or video games or whatever you're buying
well with honey the coupon code bully
has met its match
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one it finds to your
cart
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
including tech gaming and even food
delivery sites
and when you check out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click
apply coupons after a few seconds of
searching honey will apply the best
coupon it finds to save you money
off-screen producer zack recently saved
10
and got free shipping on a tabletop
board game using honey
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free and it
installs in a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
show
i never recommend something i don't use
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
big question that's joinhoney.com big
question hey empty we got some
bite-sized questions
for you to answer you ready okay let's
see we got one from uh
crispy chrissy on discord uh who
asks if there was no gauntlet to hold
the infinity stones what other article
of clothing slash apparel could be
comparable and uh how would the person
wielding it activate the stones instead
of by snapping
interesting that's a really good
question chris yeah great question
um okay so throughout the mcu we've seen
the infinity stone housed in all
different sorts of casings such as the
orb that held the power stone guardians
of the galaxy or the tesseract the
holding the space stone
and sometimes the infinity stones are
housed in items that serve practical
purposes
that harness the power of the stones for
example loki's staff holding the mine
stone or the eye of agamotto holding the
time stone we also see ronan the accuser
slap the power stone right into that
hammer for that instant planet
pulverizing
weapon upgrade in guards yeah
that's a great hammer i don't know how i
found that hammer do that but that's a
hammer what a hammer what a hammer uh
must have went to lowe's
but it wasn't until avengers infinity
war that we saw all six infinity stones
finally combined into one item a
gauntlet and this gauntlet was forged in
the furnaces
of nadivalier i hope i didn't pronounce
that wrong no
you nailed it and it's made of uru an
extremely durable metal ore
capable of withstanding the power of all
six infinity stones and of course is
also the material that thor's hammer is
made out of
and it's a really old material it's been
around since the beginning of the
universe
but yeah i digress anyway in avengers
end game tony uses nano technology to
craft another gauntlet
to hold the infinity stones and while
the nano technology seems to be able to
wield the incredible power of the stones
it still leaks a lot of that energy to
the wielder causing severe damage to the
hulk when he undoes the snap
and very uh severe fatal damage to tony
stark when he blips away everybody
at the end of avengers end game and you
know dies all right b tony sorry
but could something other than a
gauntlet wield all six stones is what my
girl crispy chrissy is asking so in
thanos number five in 2004
we saw galactus arrange all six infinity
stones into something called a
focusing crux um he was attempting to
rid himself of
his insatiable need for devouring
planets which bro
i feel you man yeah sometimes eating
just so good you just gotta
know he was attempting to rid himself of
his insatiable need for devouring
planets
but wound up opening a portal and
unleashing an interdimensional parasite
called hunger and there's no fancy
movement that galactus has to do
to activate the stones he just puts the
stones in the focusing crux
and it just works hey comics and thanos
actually tries to stop him from using
the stones
warning him that it's sort of like a
monkey's pot scenario with those stones
ah so as for what item i would choose to
hold the stones you know
that your boy gotta go with a fanny pack
you know what i'm saying it's the best
way
it's the best way to use a infinity
stone i'm just kidding i wouldn't be
caught dead with an infinity fanny pack
because
god see i would i would have like a key
tie and just like play like different
like
soul soul soul soul soul soul state soul
soul soul time soul soul oh my god i dig
it
that would be great yeah thank you for
answering that one mt i
i love that answer no problem but it is
time for our next segment of the show
it's the box of scraps of scraps
and today's box of scraps question is
eric if you could create your own branch
timeline what changes would you make oh
um i think i would just make it so that
it's it's
pretty much the way things are right now
except social media didn't have comment
sections
[Music]
remove the ability to comments that
would enter the world
if that happened the instantaneous world
peace i think you solved it
yep other than that i'll take all the
bad stuff
just get rid of that and i think it's i
think we can figure out everything from
there
honestly if for me it would just be i
would just do
the one thing that everyone's been
clamoring for for too many years
i would um make guac free like why is
black orchestra
why why guac would be free to me
you're welcome yeah mt 2024 should be
free
exactly and you know it could be for in
california the avocados
do grow on trees out here exactly so
it's so easy to find come on
free walk 2020 you can afford it
you can afford a chipotle you can afford
to give guac for free
come on but anyways that is our episode
of a big question thank you
so much to eric as always for joining me
this episode you can follow him
at eavos and you can follow me at
mastertainment all
of our social medias but most
importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are but especially on
youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload a new
video
and send us your big questions by using
the hashtag bigquestion and subscribe to
this podcast feed and give us a nice
rating and review
and all that so again subscribe to new
rockstars and we'll see you guys
next time we love you bye
[Music]
you